what's something you you talked about
being around dame earlier what was
something you learned about being around
dame dash because we spent one night
with him and i mean man the guy was just
yeah profusely just spewing jewels the
whole time yeah i mean at the time i was
like so i was like 20. i was fresh out
of college so that's 2015. it's like six
years oh yeah it was a while ago i was
23 years old
um
i mean it just learned like don't take
it personal
like you feel me like the first day i
walked in the office
about the internship you asked me like
who the [ __ ] are you like why are you in
here
and i'm just like well [ __ ] it's either
i'm gonna get upset or i'm about to
start talking and tell these [ __ ] what
i do
so i got to talking you feel me but i
think just
understanding like again personality
types understanding like how to work
with certain artists because by the time
i got to working with blast
last like a walk in the park dealing
with dame or just sitting in meetings
and taking notes and being like a minute
taking on meetings with them and [ __ ]
like that um being a fly on the wall
like all that type of stuff i think it
just helped me move into the space of
like i don't really get too imbalanced
if people be out of their mind or you
know what i'm saying or really feel like
they coming off disrespectful because
most of the time it just be people
delivery at the end of the day and if
you take this [ __ ] personally it's like
i'm not taking the [ __ ] home with me
this is basically work for real for real